en pleine crise économique le liban
affronte maintenant la deuxième vague de
covile 19 le nombre de nouveaux cas de
contamination s'approche de la barre
symbolique des cent mille personnes
infectées et la double explosion qui a
frappé beyrouth en août dernier n'a pas
aidé au contrôle de la situation
épidémiologique
bien au contraire les contaminations
quotidienne bat record sur record
résultat l'annoncé par le premier
ministre hassan diab d'un reconfirme ans
de la population du 14 au 30 novembre
prochain
l'explosion du port de beyrouth a
bouleversé les mesures mises en place
lors de la première vague du virus et
provoquer une perte de contrôle sur la
propagation de l'épidémie
nous avons atteint la ligne rouge
nous sommes aujourd'hui au stade de
danger grave en raison de l'incapacité
des hôpitaux publics et privés à
recevoir des patients dans un état
critique
car les lits d'hôpitaux sont tous déjà
remplis par des patients dans un état
critique
une craignons d'atteindre le stade où
des gens meurent dans la rue hier dans
les hôpitaux libanais c'est la
saturation
l'organisation mondiale de la santé oms
a indiqué fin octobre que 88 pour cent
des 305 places en soins intensifs du
pays étaient occupés en plus d'une
situation hospitalière critique 1500
membres du personnel médical sont
eux-mêmes attendu coronavirus